[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend während die einen mit
einander sondieren müssen andere sich
mit sich selbst beschäftigen und wunden
lecken denn nicht nur die union fühlt
sich nach dieser wahl als verliererin
die linke ist ebenfalls schwer gerupft
und auch die afg kann nicht zufrieden
sein
oppositionsführerin im bundestag ist sie
nicht mehr sondern nur noch auf platz
fünf und noch eines hat diese
bundestagswahl ziemlich deutlich gezeigt
die afg ist vor allem eine partei des
ostens in westdeutschland hat ihr die
radikalisierung geschadet im osten
hingegen nicht in sachsen und thüringen
erzielte sie besonders gute ergebnisse
daraus werden in der partei allerdings
sehr unterschiedliche schlüsse gezogen
hinzu kommen persönliche abneigungen und
so war die wahl der fraktionsführung
heute eine ziemliche schlacht david geht
hat berichtet nach zwölf stunden
streitbarer sitzung an zwei tagen kommen
endlich die frisch gewählten
fraktionsvorsitzenden aus dem
sitzungssaal es war ein pannen start
während weite lund gruppe a zu den
richtigen mikrofon nach oben fahren
fahren sich auf die abgeordnete unten
gegenseitig in die parade störer beim
interview aus der eigenen partei
geworden
sie haben eine frage gestellt und
wir haben verwalten die richtige
fraktion das muss man jetzt in den
nächsten monaten sehen ob das jetzt ob
die gräben überwunden werden in der
fraktion das werden die nächsten monate
zeigen
also wenn sie mich das mal fragen würden
dann würde ich ganz andere antwort geben
zwei stockwerke darüber präsentiert sich
währenddessen das neue du gewählt im
doppel mit 50 jahre aber auch 25 nein
stimmen wir haben grundsätzlich in
unserer partei
diskussionsfreudige mitglieder das hat
sich auch bei unseren abgeordneten
niedergeschlagen dem ist stattzugeben
wir sind sofort arbeitsfähig das ist
wichtig wir wollen die visionen
entwickeln sodass wir auch 2025
koalitionsfähig beziehungsweise auch in
der lage sind bei koalitionsgesprächen
mit dabei zu sein die ard ist
geschrumpft um fast zweieinhalb
prozentpunkte platz fünf statt drei
oppositionsführerschaft weg dafür aber
16 direktmandate im osten vertreter des
extrem rechten national sozialen kurses
sehen sich weiter im aufwind dass herr
höcker durch dieses wahlergebnis
gestärkt ich denke mal schon ist
natürlich klar dass es schwer fällt und
als alb die thüringen anzugreifen wenn
wir die einzigen sind die im boom
zugelegt haben die neue fdp fraktion
bleibt insgesamt wohl mindestens so
radikal wie die alte neu dabei etwa ein
vom militärischen abschirmdienst als
extremist eingestufter soldat ein
suspendierter polizist und neulinge die
der sogenannten querdenker bewegung
nahestehen
einer wird nicht teil der afg fraktion
mathias helferich verzichtet nach
heftiger diskussion freiwillig er hatte
sich unter anderem in einem chat das
freundliche gesicht des ns also
nationalsozialismus genannt
parteimitglied ist er nach
nationalsozialistisches gedankengut und
der hätte mal eingreifen müssen hätte
ich mir auch vom bundesvorstand der
partei gewünscht
ehrenvorsitzender der fraktion wurde
übrigens alexander gauland der soll so
erzählen es teilnehmer heute einem
kritiker an den kopf geworfen haben
früher hat man sowas im duell gelöst es
war denkwürdig heute
ja wenn man auf die anderen parteien
schauen theo koll in berlin wie geht's
denn bei den sondierungen jetzt weiter
es geht weiter mit speed dating also
eine phase politischer partnersuche im
eiltempo morgen vormittag schon treffen
sich jetzt schon zum zweiten mal grüne
und fdp die von dir wollen dann so heißt
es auch schon inhalt nicht reden und am
sonntag trifft sich dann erst die spd
mit der fdp dann trifft sich die union
mit der fdp und danach spd und grüne es
wird also ein tag der einheit in
vielfalt heute haben übrigens schon alle
ihre sondiere teams benannt wobei manche
gleich in mannschaftsstärke an rücken
wollen und die beste nachricht übrigens
für uns berichterstatter hatten heute
die grün man wolle auf jeden fall
diesmal die unendlichen nachtsitzungen
vermeiden und das ist wahrscheinlich für
eine gute nachricht steckt vielen das
trauma von 2017 an den knochen
absolut und zwar in vielfacher hinsicht
vermieden soll ja unter anderem das
wochenlange schaulaufen auf dem
berühmten balkon der parlamentarischen
gesellschaft wo das pausen miteinander
der verhandler ja öffentlich zelebriert
und beobachtet wurde vor allem aber will
man schneller und diskreter seien die
erarbeiteten papiere sollen nicht sofort
und ständig durch gestochen werden das
erste geheime treffen das wege sehen
haben vor zwei tagen mit dem instagram
foto das kann man glaube ich bewusst als
willenserklärung für genau diesen
anderen stil verstehen wobei der ort für
das morgige treffen ist jetzt ganz
offiziell angekündigt worden man trifft
sich in einem an mietbaren coolen büro
direkt am berliner zu und ich ahne dass
das auch nicht ohne eine gewisse präsenz
der medien stattfinden dürfte das ist zu
erwarten ebenfalls interessant dass er
parallel geredet wird mit mit spd und
union wer verfolgter welche strategien
also armin laschet hat glaube ich die
schwierigste und zugleich einfachste
ausgangslage für ihn gilt kanzler oder
rentner deshalb will er nicht die ampel
gespräche der spd abwarten sollen schon
jetzt aktiv für jamaika werden das ist
ja seine einzige option söder dagegen
spielt die chancen für jamaika
weitgehend runter das könnte strategisch
gedacht sein also er könnte damit
folgendes bezwecken dass grüne und fdp
dadurch weniger trümpfe bei der spd in
der hand haben die spd ihn also weniger
anbietet und dass am ende dann für
jamaika spricht die spd wiederum
behandelt die beiden kleineren parteien
besonders respektvoll spricht heute
sogar von augenhöhe und auch grüne und
fdp behandeln sich weitgehend pfleglich
wobei das nicht zu immer ganz gelingt
jürgen trittin meinte heute die fdp habe
dazugelernt und das hatte er als lob
gedacht also da kann noch viele schicken
dargestellt theo wir beobachten dass
vor lauter wahlkampf ist das thema krone
in den letzten wochen ja etwas in den
hintergrund geraten es ist aber immer
noch da und die einschlägigen experten
befürchten dass sie im oktober oder
november die zahlen wieder so nach oben
gehen dass das auch die krankenhäuser zu
spüren bekommen werden dort landen
hauptsächlich ungeimpften und von denen
gibt es nach wie vor sehr viele zu den
ungeimpften gehören natürlich auch
kinder unter zwölf jahren für die es
noch keinen zugelassenen impfstoff gibt
trotzdem haben mehrere bundesländer
beschlossen die masken pflicht an
schulen aufzuheben oder zumindest zu
lockern in bayern zum beispiel muss ab
montag im unterricht keine maske mehr
getragen werden sarah show berichtet
acht stunden unterricht mit maske für
die abiturklasse des huber ganztags
gymnasiums in münchen war das in den
letzten wochen mitunter ziemlich
anstrengend denn obwohl bei ihnen die
meisten schülerinnen und schüler schon
geimpft sind mussten sie seit ende der
sommerferien einen mund nasen schutz
tragen täglich bis zum schulschluss am
späten nachmittag dass sie die maske ab
kommender woche ablegen dürfen darüber
freuen sich hier alle ich bin eher
erleichtert vor allem wenn man sie dann
und auch bei den klausuren ablegen kann
in der zwischenklasse muss man sich
natürlich auch ganz besonders
konzentrieren also es war denke ich
schon eine belastung bis jetzt aber
dadurch dass halt relativ viele leute
mittlerweile 15 dass die luftfilter
haben und dadurch dass auch er nicht
geimpfte leute noch getestet werden
denke ich kann mir das auch durchaus
verantworten ich bin auch der meinung
dass man nicht ausschließen kann dass
man die masse kreationen späteren
zeitpunkt wieder einführt das wurde ja
auch in den in der letzten zeit wieder
so gehandhabt er leicht hat es doch
schulleiter florian huber zu seinem
schulverbund gehört eine grundschule
huber ist überzeugt gerade für die
jüngsten unter den schülern ist die
masten pflicht ein problem wir sehen
aber schon gerade in der grundschule bei
den erstklässlern dass die begegnung mit
maske ganz schwierig ist das bedeutet
also das kennenlernen das vertrauen
schaffen fehlende mimik gerade
beispielsweise dann auch später beim
erlernen von fremdsprachen und deren
aussprache dass es ganz schön schwierig
mit maske weg mit der maske im
unterricht das haben die bundesländer
bayern berlin und das saarland ab der
kommenden woche beschlossen über eine
lockerung nachdenken wollen auch
nordrhein westfalen und baden
württemberg bremen thüringen sachsen
anhalt und mecklenburg vorpommern haben
die masken pflicht im unterricht bereits
abgeschafft in den übrigen bundesländern
gilt sie noch teilweise mit
einschränkungen ausgerechnet die sonst
eher vorsichtige bayerische
staatsregierung geht bei den lockerungen
voran und begründet das mit besseren
testmöglichkeiten die pool pcr test in
den grundschulen und förderschulen aber
auch sonst ein engmaschiges testsystem
das wären positive proben sind sogar
noch aktiviert wird dann wird noch mehr
getestet wir haben luftreiniger wir
haben lüftungssysteme die spiegel alles
daran dass weiterhin vorsicht an den
schulen geboten ist das zeigt vor allem
die sieben tage incidence bei kindern
und jugendlichen
bei den fünf- bis neunjährigen liegt die
aktuell bei 139 bei den zehn- bis
14-jährigen sogar bei 168 befürchte dass
es in den schulen auch zu ausbrüchen
kommen wird gerade wenn man die masken
jetzt weglassen wird im unterricht weil
wir eben keinen aktiven schutz für die
kinder bieten können unter zwölf jahren
durch impfungen ist zu befürchten dass
dort entsprechend infektionsgeschehen
stattfinden wird bayer macht heute schon
einmal klar sollte es die situation
erfordern können die masken pflicht im
unterricht jederzeit wieder eingeführt
werden wie es einige schüler des
gymnasiums schon befürchten sie würden
das gerne in kauf nehmen wenn sie dafür
im präsenzunterricht bleiben dürfen und
mit den aktuellen corona zahlen macht
uns jetzt weiter da gibt es heute im
wochenvergleich einen erneuten anstieg
bei den infektionszahlen das
robert-koch-institut hat
12.150 neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
tages registriert das sind
1454 mehr als vor einer woche
67 todesfälle kamen binnen 24 stunden
hinzu die sieben tage incident steigt
auf 63
ein großteil der zeitweise mehr als 400
regionalen impfzentren in deutschland
wird von morgen an geschlossen bleiben
das hatten die gesundheitsminister von
bund und ländern im juni beschlossen sie
setzen künftig auf impfungen den
arztpraxen und mobile angebote
vollständig geimpft sind nach angaben
des lka inzwischen 53,6 millionen
menschen das entspricht 64 4 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung
beim synodalen weg dem reform dialog der
katholischen kirche in deutschland hat
heute die nächste etappe begonnen mit
der zweiten synodale versammlung in
frankfurt am main zum auftrag gab es
eine aussprache über die papst
entscheidungen zum verbleib des
hamburger erzbischofs heese und des
kölner kardinals woelki in ihren ämtern
auf der tagesordnung der versammlung die
bis samstag dauert themen wie zölibat
machtverteilung und die rolle der frau
in der kirche
der womöglich letzte ns prozess in
deutschland konnte nicht wie geplant
beginnen die 96 jährige angeklagte
erschien nicht zur verhandlung was sie
per brief zuvor angekündigt hatte sie
wurde später von der polizei gefasst das
gericht hatte die verhandlungen bereits
auf mitte oktober verschoben die
angeklagte arbeitete von juni 1943 bis
april 1945 als sekretärin im ehemaligen
konzentrationslager stutthof ihr wird
beihilfe zum mord in 11.000 fällen
vorgeworfen
der us-kongress hat in letzter minute
einen drohenden teil stillstand der
regierungsgeschäfte einen sogenannten
shutdown abgewendet senat und
repräsentantenhaus stimmten einer
übergangsfinanzierung für die regierung
bis anfang dezember zu damit kann die
budget regelung noch kurz vor ablauf
einer entscheidenden frist heute um
mitternacht in kraft gesetzt werden bei
einem shut down hätten etwa
staatsbedienstete zum teil zwangs
beurlaubt werden oder vorübergehend ohne
bezahlung arbeiten müssen
frankreichs frühere präsident nicolas
sarkozy ist wegen illegaler
wahlkampffinanzierung schuldig
gesprochen und zu einem jahr haft
verurteilt worden er darf die strafe zu
hause absitzen und muss eine
elektronische fußfessel tragen gegen das
urteil des akkus sie aber berufung
einlegen und bleibt somit vorerst auf
freiem fuß für seinen
präsidentschaftswahlkampf im jahr 2012
soll der konservative politiker nach
ansicht des gerichts fast doppelt so
viel wie erlaubt ausgegeben und versucht
haben die kosten auf illegale weise
abzurechnen
jeder der schon mal gebaut oder auch nur
umgebaut hat weiß was da auf einen
zukommt dass die kosten immer höher
werden als man anfangs dachte dass
sachen schief laufen die man sich nicht
ausmalen konnte das handwerker oft
völlig ausgebucht sind oder plötzlich
baumaterial ungeahnt lange auf sich
warten lässt mit all dem werden es jetzt
auch die menschen im aartal zu tun
bekommen wenn sie ihre häuser und
geschäfte wiederaufbau der stadt
verspricht hilfe heute hielt das land
rheinland pfalz eine zukunftskonferenz
ab für die flut geschädigten die viele
sorgen und fragen haben robbie keane
berichtet neun häuser mussten bisher in
dem ort schuld abgerissen werden zu groß
waren die schäden nach dem hochwasser
erzählt uns ortsbürgermeister helmut
fluss sie erst vor kurzem wurde ihm
mitgeteilt vier dieser häuser dürfen
nicht wieder aufgebaut werden weil die
hochwassermarke seitens der
wasserbehörden so hoch gesetzt wird dass
sie bei einer eventuellen flut oder
eines hochwassers denn gefahr laufen
wieder überschwemmt zu werden
und das ist uns jetzt bekannt von der
oberen unteren wasserbehörde flächen
direkt an der a fallen als bauland weg
die suche nach neuen grundstücken läuft
das haus von roger buchmann in altena
hat die flut stark beschädigt
überstanden alle anderen häuser in der
straße wurden vom wasser mitgerissen
buchmann fragt sich jetzt wie der ort
künftig aussehen soll also warten als
bürger klare antworten wo wiederaufbau
gebaut werden kann und in welcher form
wieder aufgebaut werden kann und wir
erwarten uns natürlich auch aussagen
dazu welche hochwasserschutz maßnahmen
ergriffen werden können um gebiete hier
direkt an der art zu sichern um solche
und andere themen ging es heute bei der
zukunftskonferenz des landes
rheinland-pfalz gebäude hausrat
öffentliche infrastruktur all das kann
mit hilfe der 15 milliarden fluthilfe
bezuschusst werden unterstützung soll es
laut landesregierung bereits bei der
beantragung der gelder geben angefangen
von architekten gutachter natürlich auch
menschen die sich mit der fragestellung
auskennen um möglichst vielen bürgern
bürgerinnen die fragen haben wirklich
auch ein gutes netz von beratung zur
verfügung zu stellen um ihre ganz
individuellen fragen dann eben auch
klären zu können seit montag können
anträge online gestellt werden doch die
werfen fragen auf denn darin heißt es
ersetzt werden bis zu 80 prozent der
zuwendungsfähigen gesamtausgaben
die restlichen 20 prozent müssen sie
selbst aufbringen eine formulierung die
bürgermeister lussi aus schuld
kritisiert
die bekommen 80 prozent in härtefällen
100 da könnte ich sagen ihr bekommt 80
überkommt runde aber dieses bis das
bereitet mir magenschmerzen vielleicht
bekommen wir nur 60 prozent das heißt er
kann elf wochen sind seit der
flutkatastrophe vergangen lucy hofft auf
schnelle und unbürokratische hilfe sowie
viele menschen im aartal
von einem extremen naturereignis wird
derzeit ja auch die insel la palma
heimgesucht sorgen machen insbesondere
die giftigen gase die entstehen wenn
sich der glühende lava strom ins meer
wasser ergießt zum glück steht der wind
bisher noch so dass er die gase von der
insel weg trägt das kann sich allerdings
bald ändern und das ist nicht die
einzige angst die die bewohner in
alarmbereitschaft hält einen bericht
der vulkan lässt die insel wachsen um
eine fläche von 14 fußballfeldern
bereits die lava ergieße sich ins meer
tag und nacht 1000 grad treffen auf 20
grad es dampft giftige gase steigen auf
und so herrscht ausgangssperre etwa in
tasa korte im westen der insel die
anwohner sollen vorsorglich zu hause
bleiben oder den ort verlassen emilys
wert betreibt einen schmuckladen in dem
küstenstädtchen die behörden haben ihr
erlaubt nach dem rechten zu sehen
das geschäft ist tot jetzt geht es nur
noch darum sich gegenseitig zu
unterstützen und ums überleben alles
kann noch passieren wir müssen darauf
vorbereitet sein ohne in panik zu
geraten
mit panic meldungen über verletzte oder
gar tote gibt es nicht seit dem
vulkanausbruch vor elf tagen doch lava
asche und gesteinsbrocken haben die
lebensgrundlage vieler inselbewohner
zerstört gefährden tourismus und
landwirtschaft bereits jetzt konnten
etwa eine million tonnen bananen nicht
geerntet werden viele früchte sind für
den verkauf inzwischen ungeeignet
[Applaus]
ein großer teil der ernte hier wird wohl
auch verloren gehen weil die bananen
schon ziemlich reich sind und es wird
schwer sein sie zu reinigen
wir sind hier 30 leute und wenn die
firma verluste macht schickt sie uns in
kurzarbeit das ist unsere sorge
pedro wohnt derzeit bei seiner schwester
denn sein haus liegt in der gefahrenzone
ungewiss wann er zurückkehren darf
ungewiss wie lange la palma noch
katastrophengebiet bleibt
es sieht so aus dass wir den lavastrom
kanalisieren konnten aber ich möchte
betonen dass der vulkanausbruch nicht
unter kontrolle ist es gibt eine dynamik
die wir weiterhin genau beobachten
müssen
andauernde alarm zustand auf der insel
liegen die nerven blank
von unseren kollegen die vor ort im
einsatz sind haben wir gerade erfahren
dass der vulkan wieder mehr lava gestein
aus seinem hauptquartier ausschluss
[Musik]
der vulkan scheint nicht aufzugeben
hüllt die insel in eine dichte wolke aus
asche und rauch la palma wird nicht mehr
so sein wie früher
wirken sich solche vulkanausbrüche
eigentlich auch aufs klima aus eine
antwort darauf gibt es am ende der
sendung im wetter mit
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit
wirtschaftsthemen da geht es zunächst um
die enorm gestiegene inflationsrate die
inflation in deutschland hat im
september nach ersten berechnungen die
vier prozent marke überschritten zum
ersten mal sehr knapp 28 jahren jetzt
ist die große frage wie geht es weiter
mit der preissteigerung aber war der
reha ja vorher noch woher kommt diese
entwicklung im moment ja ganz
verschiedene faktoren lieferengpässe zum
einen dadurch werden vorprodukte und
rohstoffe teurer
seit januar gelten ja auch wieder die
regulären mehrwertsteuersätze und
dadurch ziehen die preise von vielen
waren eben automatisch an entscheidender
faktor aber sind einmal mehr die extrem
gestiegenen energiekosten
rohöl wird im zuge der
konjunkturerholung stark nachgefragt ja
und hinzu kommt die co2 steuer die beim
verbrennen von diesel benzin heizöl und
gas an fällt das macht die energie zum
großen preistreiber plus 14 3 prozent im
vergleich zum vorjahr deutlich teurer
aber wurden auch lebensmittel um fast
fünf prozent dass das noch nicht der
höhepunkt ist vermutet die bundesbank
sie erwartet dass die inflation im
jahresverlauf weiter steigt auf
zeitweise 5 prozent ein vorübergehen das
phänomen sagt die ezb eine folge der
pandemie unter ökonomen wachsen die
zweifel ob die inflation tatsächlich
nächstes jahr deutlich sinkt auch die
amerikanische notenbank rudert
inzwischen zurück und warnt dass die
preise länger hoch bleiben könnten als
gedacht anleger sind zunehmend
verunsichert vom hohen preisanstieg der
dax verliert heute spürbar und beendet
den monat mit über dreieinhalb prozent
im minus der september macht seinem ruf
als schwacher börsenmonat damit alle
ehre
vielen dank
angesichts der steigenden energiepreise
hat frankreich nun angekündigt die
tarife für gas und strom für die
wintermonate zu deckeln premierminister
kan stacks sagte es gehe darum die
kaufkraft der franzosen zu schützen bis
april werde der gaspreis nicht die ab
anfang oktober geltenden tarife
übersteigen und bis zum jahresende auch
der strompreis nicht erhöht
die lage am deutschen arbeitsmarkt
entwickelt sich weiterhin positiv laut
bundesagentur für arbeit nimmt die zahl
der beschäftigten zu zugleich sinke die
zahl der kurzarbeitenden deutlich
insgesamt waren im september zwei
millionen
465.000 menschen arbeitslos gemeldet das
sind 114 1000 weniger als im august die
quote sinkt auf 5,4 prozent im vergleich
zum september des vorjahres waren
382.000 menschen weniger ohne job
ein ergebnis aus der
fußball-europa-league vom abend
eintracht frankfurt hat im zweiten
gruppenspiel bei royal antwerpen eins zu
null gewonnen
die weltausstellung expo wird morgen in
dubai für besucher öffnen pandemie
bedingt mit einem jahr verspätung
heute abend hat bereits die
eröffnungsfeier der expo stattgefunden
mit dem emirat dubai ist erstmals ein
arabisches land ausrichter der expo
pavillons aus rund 190 staaten
präsentieren überwiegend ideen zu den
themen nachhaltigkeit und mobilität bis
ende märz rechnen die veranstalter mit
25 millionen besuchern
die dixence sind in berlin so etwas wie
kunst helden echte pioniere der street
art szene
2017 schafften sie auf anhieb einen
ausstellungs fit für die in die berliner
szene schlange stand und schließlich
auch touristen aus aller welt kam um
will haus zu sehen the house war ein
hässliches bürogebäude in der nähe vom
bahnhof zoo das zum abriss leerstand
doch bevor die abrissbirnen kamen rohde
aus dem haus noch kurz am ende redete
die ganze stadt darüber ob man schon in
der haus war jetzt gibt es ein neues
projekt wieder an einem ort an dem man
kunst er nicht erwartet nächste woche
dienstag ist der öffnung henriette de
maizière durfte schon mal rein
eine verlassene spielhalle die zum
temporären kunstort wird
2000 quadratmeter im monat am neuen
dorfplatz im alten berliner westen als
wir angekommen sind das erste mal dieses
alte spielcasino was 35 jahre irgendwie
eine spielhölle waren wo alle leute ihr
geld verzockt haben wo man ja erst mal
das gefühl hatte es irgendwie so ein
komisches kammer dann standen wir vor
der tür haben gedacht
nennen wenn das baby game over
game over das spiel ist aus kunst im
abrisshaus für maximal ein jahr mit dem
haus haben dass die dixence 2017 schon
mal erfolgreich gemacht vergangene büro
einöde wurde für kurze zeit zu einer
nicht ein kunstwelt nun ein neuer ort
machen wir jetzt das genau ist das was
uns spaß macht
dazu wissen was morgen passiert macht
uns total spaß und daraus ist entstanden
dass wir zwei der künstler analoge
künstler mit digitalen künstlern 3d
künstler kombinieren und was ganz feines
was ganz feines zaubern aus den
geordneten chaos der zivilisation
fließen bei cosimo zum beispiel die
bedrohten und ausgestorbenen arten
sozusagen gefühl dass wir über der natur
stehen als menschen da und wir machen
uns die natur wir nutzen die hieraus für
unsere bedürfnisse haben und dabei
müsste das in balance sein und auf
augenhöhe sein
gesellschaftskritik auch beim
künstlerkollektiv drink and drop ich
habe mich für das thema medien
entschieden man fühlt sich sehr
überwältigt und ich fühle mich dann so
als würde ich eigentlich verschlungen
werden von den medien
mehr als 60 künstlerinnen und künstler
experimentieren hier der besondere clou
zu vielen gezeigten werken gibt es
sogenannte nfc es digital verschlüsselte
objekte zum runterladen aufs handy
mft sind digitale kunstwerke die es nur
einmal gibt und wo wenn du es gekauft
hast nur du derjenige bist er den
schlüssel hat um sich dieses kunstwerk
digital anzuschauen wir haben hier ein
spielplatz kreiert wo wir aus berlin in
die ganze welt die besten apps die es
jemals gegeben hat daraus geworden und
man wir sind halt wieder wie genauso wie
bei der aus die ersten erster die sonne
so eine experience schaffen und so ist
die welt von game over auf ein go für
die zukunft
ja jetzt gibt es erstmal eine politische
experience maybrit illner stellt ihren
gästen die frage die sich gerade alle
stellen laschet oder scholz den machen
grüne und fdp zum kanzler und um 0.30
meldet sich dann christopher wehrmann
mit unserem heute-journal update
wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend und willkommen zum wetter
der vulkanausbruch brachte auf der insel
la palma spektakuläre bilder von
lavaströmen hat aber kaum globalen
einfluss auf das klima vulkane stoßen
nicht nur lava aus sondern zahlreiche
gase überwiegend wasserdampf der
kondensiert und fällt als niederschlag
zum vergleich kommt es zu einer größeren
explosion können gase und asche bis in
die stratosphäre gelangen sie zum
beispiel vor 30 jahren beim ausbruch des
pinatubo auf den philippinen bis über 30
kilometer höhe dort wirken sie wie ein
schirm und lassen weniger
sonnenstrahlung zur erde somit hat ein
vulkanausbruch genau den gegenteiligen
effekt erklärt das klima und heißt es
nicht auf
ein bild von dem ausbruch vor 30 jahren
und dieser ausbruch sorgte tatsächlich
dann in der folge für eine abkühlung von
der globalen mitteltemperatur von gut
einem halben grad schauen wir auf das
aktuelle wetter und da haben wir es mit
einem tief zu tun was eine kaltfront in
unsere richtung schiebt und der regen
kommt dann am morgigen abend an in der
nacht gibt es noch regen und im süden da
klar dass dann größtenteils auf und es
bildet sich nebel temperaturen bis 2
grad zwölf grad dann an der nordsee ja
und morgen dann erst einmal trocken aber
von westen her kommen neue wolken mit
regen auf im südosten da ist es
größtenteils sonnig bei höchsten
temperaturen bis 22 grad am oberrhein
und 16 grad an der ostsee die kommenden
tage ja am samstag etwas regen von
westen her und in der nacht auf sonntag
dann teils kräftiger regen und viel wind
bis 26 grad ein schöner art